so if i win this game i'll finish with 6
out of 11
which will be half way better than the
previous tournament
and we do have a prediction going so
i'm going to try and prove all the
doubters wrong
we have more believers and doubters
thankfully
queen e7
queen e7 usually calls for this move
just preventing e5
interesting it'll take
ah queen ticks
yeah it's kind of a funny line
i think i'm supposed to take here
hmm
might be threatening some greek gift
also preventing e5 again
i'm really tempted to play h4
just for the style points
and then take and then this
oh it's probably really bad
but how bad
oh there's also just king h6 in that
line
yeah let's not do that
i'll play e4 let's try him in this game
down a little bit of time
um
yeah the queen's a little bit awkward on
g7 we might just be trading like takes
takes
takes takes develop castle
calculating this this this and then
knight g5
takes takes and i'm threatening made in
two but g6 in the end
this idea queen
queen a fourth running this
it's also b4b5
maybe i'll play that
luck eric oh thank you nanodonk
okay
allowing some bishop check but
now i have
i have my own bishop check
this looks enticing
there's a funny line this this
queen moves somewhere check takes and
then i take back and meeting
and here the king is justified on f1
because the rook is serving a purpose on
each file
yeah these pieces are a bit restricted
um
i want to just play this and have fun
okay let's do it
i mean this is still a clear threat even
if the knight takes
after pawn takes
the whole point is open h-file
and destroy the king
oh it's really close to working
h6
i think what i do is i take the queen
and i play bishop d6
slight in between move i want to remove
the knight and then set up my mating
idea
so if a move like this is played i take
take and then it's force mate
takes takes bishop blocks and then mate
there is a move rook here but then i
think just bishop b3
or just take some takes
yeah even though queen's already traded
i still have like an interesting mating
attack
okay so still bishop b3
opponent sees it like that's why they're
not playing rookie 8
or moving them i mean the knight doesn't
really have much squares maybe it could
move here though
ah
and after here here here there's knight
h6
okay so
should be seven
not so much time
maybe i'll play this first
and lock's still a little bit stuck rook
c3i bishop d5
um
i just want a smothered pork mate
oh it might happen
oh no my pawn
oh no my rook
don't know my bishop
what is this game
[Music]
i didn't see that coming